between the legs and between the legs that was
simply outstanding let's hcky baby yeah M Mar
has all our [Music] reactions ahead moving
in shoot scar what a remarkable look here by
Matias AKO he goes back finds theak he's got
his head up the whole way he knows mcdavid's
there and this is no Chin for Peter morz that
pass is a bullet it's right on the tape what a
gorgeous feed from Matias EOL and McDavid
does not make any mistake with the slick
finish Rossi goes to McCade chopped on go they
score what a sweet tip it's charner with a chop
shot on a pass that's going way wide that is
really well done to create the angle but also
to get it in the air and rattle around the
hands of cocking and to slide in behind him
perfect that is really nice from Mitch mder for
the first time of the period last long chips the
bar now connect me connect me there go got it
in front and score my goodness here's the skill
little backand tow drag then the will to take
it to the blue paint and he's going to the net
hard and as he does that puck just rolls off his
stick and Fool's ter off for Vince done cross ice
Everly toar sprung free he scores that's hockey
baby to Marsh Tatar set up beautifully boy what
a pass by Jordan Everly watch the play by Tatar
you wonder how does a player get that wide open
Shabbat goes wide the quick little one touch
and what a move by Tomas Tatar beautiful [Music]
move Alexander Holtz goes the other way 20
seconds left in the period flips It Wide but
Cloud driving back cand he scores Michael McLoud
worlds it in and the big hit in the devil's own
by by Michael McLoud boom now he's going to
hustle he's going to win this race up the
ice not only does he win it he battles to stay
alive and as he's falling down throws it on net
it starts a one end and then he finishes it off
just strength on Puck and will to put it on the
net and the Bruins come out with coil gots him
hel Maran cuts it back in for he scores look at
him handle this Puck through the feet of Chris
Laten stick battling for the puck for position
with Lank once twice now he gets through and
with the agility that he has he got the game's
first goal to give the Bruins a one- nothing
lead he's got their fifth per with a headman
pass up to Hegel Hegel Cuts in St with st what a
great set of hands by Brandon Hegel and he had to
fight his way with the puck through traffic that
was simply outstanding spinning around that is a
beautiful little move at high speed while he's
spinning from forwards to backwards controlling
it nobody knocks him down and he finds a way
just Wills this one into the back of the net
back to the way comes Hegel Hegel drops it out
to KRA K nice move he's in back pass shot scor
the between the feet to maintain possession and
then the backand pass that's what really paid
it off to maintain possession by doing the in
between the feet is one thing but to have the
vision to make a backhand backward pass like
onto the tape to Braden Point coming in late
on the play that is just crazy off charge stop
looked like they might have a chance to pick
it off and go with numbers the other way here's
suding P Suter across nice move by H scores NS
homelander between the legs and a backhander
along the ice su's going to hold it and then
find hoglander between the legs and between the
legs oh man through his legs and through sherin's
[Music] legs forberg heberg sh a go score oh one
H P's homg with his first goal in 19 games you'd
never know it that is nice the strength get the
leg out and again to elevate it over the pad of
cocken by Holberg is beauty rolls it and flicks
it yeah F Marner has all our reactions helloow
oin slings it ahead good bounce ketov scores bit
of a broken play on the pass from oetkin ketov
lights the L vkin reads it through beautiful pick
up by KET off gets a rolling pu how about that
play shoveled it high and then swept it in was a
big free agent addition backand poock scores goal
scorers have this patience to sense poock doesn't
even Flinch as NAD delovic has to come all the way
across the net and tostock looks up sees that
NAD delovic is going fast right to left he just
goes back the other way and pasta's on the board
too taken away by Anderson now s down the right
side G line Anderson Anderson cuts to the middle
Anderson back hand scores this is just patience he
just out Waits everybody here's Anderson slows
everybody down beats one defense beats another
defense and then casually with a beautiful back
head takes it off and skates up and on the far
side stick side I mean that's just a beautiful
goal by Anderson he beats kachuk Blackwell scores
Floris kachuk with a pass for Colin Blackwell
all alone in front it's Blackwell's first goal
of the Season Blackwell makes a beautiful cut
back move right there getting the golender to
move to his left little forehand brings it back
to the backend and thanks for coming right into
the empty net pinsky's on it in the corner he
wedges it only to the blue line where nit keeps
it in holds in the slot spins it back nit for
hold open he scores that was a thing of beauty
great k keep in by nit Holtz gets it to nit after
the keep in and he goes to the net follows up and
look at that Vision by Alex Holtz the spin her out
pass the Katch and release as he gets it back from
nemit and buries it to TI this game bounces theil
SWS it out here's a breakway here's huo right on
Q scores great play up here on the board toil
goes huo Waits Waits and oh what a play I mean
he comes back he's got a Long Reach and watch
how he uses his reach here to come back against
the flow up over top of Carter H right underneath
the bar that is a beautiful goal oh now a chance
for Conor Garland to get it back goes round the
net R around he scores Devils get mixed up in the
neutral zone driving continues scly gets suck on
the glove side Garland whips it on the wrap around
and in less than 12 seconds the Cs get their
two goal lead back and it sucks the life right
out of credential Center H drop and picked off
here by the jackets marchenko drops it into the
shot and scores what a play by marenko to pick off
Middleton and as he tries to make a move marchenko
strips him here comes Middleton there's Marko
now he's going to draw the attention low and he
knows he's got cylinder up high cylinder's in a
perfect spot just hoping that puck comes to him
and as he does it's top shell face off what they
score a tmy paner we talked about face off that's
a really smart play that time tro he goes back
so often watch him go forward and then he goes
and gets it just sles it over bang bang it's in
the net so troch again with a smart play another
primary assist for him and panan with another goal
now stal but it's eers jumping up and he'll get it
ahead and Mark sley is going to take off here
comes Mark sley scores as soon as sh puts this
one in the back of the net he turns and looks up
ice because he wants to give credit where credit
is due and it's to number 27 what an outstanding
play defensively from his linemate Nikolai eers
could stick to jar the Puck loose and force a
turnover now you spring your partner Mark shley
forehand backhand he elevates that one enough
there are no passengers in this game for either
team here's patteron in Le PS nice move stop getes
a rebound takes it in what a play Patterson with
the dangles the shot the rebound and the Finish s
off ice gets it back holds it back pocket skips it
gets it and as he's getting knocked to the ice the
wherewithal to go below the goal line above the
goal line put that stick handle in the net Tander
has a look feeds across the Matthews Taps it back
and shoot scores off man how about the angles they
work into the bumper to Mar he has a shot threat
but Matthews then flers back out deeper he's
got his bottom skate on the circle and look at
the angle just pops into the top of the net look
at the Islanders stop playing for a minute like
they thought the puck could come outside the line
maybe it did but plays continuing here's Hughes
cutting in front he shoots he scores that is
quintessential Hughes after a chance earlier and
Hughes realizes he can cut to the middle nobody
really comes to him after a couple of shoulder
fakes and a nice little turnaround and this is
going to go through traffic pass the roken Who's
down and had no idea it's pass the blocker I mean
he almost went through Five Guys Five Guys yeah
[Music] fries [Music]
d